Our program is mostly made possible by folks
like you who grab a membership and join Pakman
Dotcom, you can use the coupon code if you
so please, to get a big discount.
That coupon code is better.
Twenty one, all one word, all lowercase.
A few interesting posts on The David Pakman
Show sub Reddit.
I invite you to join us there.
Respectful political discussion with just
27000 of our closest friends in the audience.
You can go to David Pakman dotcom slash Reddit,
a very interesting post about what if what
happened on January 6th had happened when
Barack Obama had been president and what if
it was 2012 and Obama had lost to Mitt Romney,
but insisted he actually won and spent months
promoting on Twitter and Facebook that he
won and that Mitt Romney had stolen the election.
And then on the day when the Electoral College
votes were being counted, Barack Obama went
to a rally and told Antifa and Black Lives
Matter people, let's go to the capital.
And then they did.
And they broke into the Capitol and a police
officer died.
Do you think that the reactions would have
been the same from Republicans?
What do you think we would be seeing on Fox
News?
What do you think we would be seeing from
the standpoint of of the Republican Party
on the floors of the House and the Senate?
Give me a break, guys.
You need only imagine that scenario to see
the level of hypocrisy and dishonesty and
immorality that we are seeing from Republicans
today.
Very, very good post.
Also, an interesting question from a user
who goes by the name Fred Allosaurus on our
sub Reddit who says, Will Trump divulge state
secrets when he's out of office?
I'm worried of the national security risk
that Trump will represent when out of office,
because even if he can be removed from the
office, he surely has state secrets in his
head that obviously can't be removed.
I'm surprised he hasn't spilled already, but
I'm wondering if any of you think he will
use his knowledge of state secrets as a bargaining
chip with his cronies or who knows?
I wouldn't be surprised if the Russians approach
him undercover or not and try to get him to
divulge some of the things that would be useful
to them.
I don't actually think so.
And there's a couple of things.
Number one, and this was actually mentioned
in the comments, Trump hasn't been reading
his presidential daily briefings for a long
time.
He hasn't even been receiving them orally
for a long time.
So Trump knows way fewer state secrets than
most presidents because he's not been paying
attention for a very long time and he doesn't
really care.
Number two, I don't actually think Trump would
would do something like selling state secrets
for cash or anything like that.
I don't think that he would be morally against
it.
I just don't think that it would end up being
put together.
But I do think it's quite plausible that in
order to brag, Trump will say things to people.
He's not supposed to be saying things too
often with Trump, much of his behavior comes
out of incompetence or narcissism rather than
out of malice, although there's no shortage
of malice for for sure.
But let me know what you think about that
and join the discussion at
David Pakman Dotcom, slash it.